novel of Kristen Gore daughter of former
Vice President Al Gore this talk is a
half hour I am really happy to be here I
am very excited to be able to share some
of this book with you I actually though
I've been writing for five years
professionally for TV I never thought
that I would write about politics and
and it's it was very fun for me to
explore a world that I knew very well
but in a fictional way and kind of try
to combine the comedy writing with this
world and trying to make it accessible
and what I hoped would be a funny
entertaining way I didn't think that
being a writer entailed public speaking
so I'm feeling a little duped by that
but I'm getting some practice doing it
and I wanted to read I should introduce
Sammy a little bit because probably it's
just came out and probably you all
haven't read it but Sammy is 26 years
old she's from Ohio and she moves to DC
to work for her home state senator and
to basically try to change the world try
to make it a better place this is a
really pure impulse in her that
sometimes makes her a little naive but
it definitely keeps her motivated she is
very smart and hardworking and really
trying to make a difference but like a
lot of 26 year olds she doesn't have her
life completely together some people
would say she's neurotic other people
would just say she has an active
imagination she tends to imagine
worst-case scenarios and has a lot going
on in her head she's a bit she works in
health care and that fuels some
hypochondria that she has as she also
solicits romantic advice from
telemarketers she really enjoys talking
to them and thinks they get a bad rap
from other people she is in addition her
sort of hypochondria came about from her
this course she took in college on
infectious diseases that sort of focused
her in on health care but also made her
really scared that anytime she had a
sore throat it
maybe wasn't the flu maybe it could be a
bola or also concerned that these things
that befall the other people could
happen to her these were scare scenario
things so she wants to know what what
could happen if she were to lose a limb
she'd be very unprepared and she needs
to worry about that so I'll read just a
little bit from the beginning of the
book that kind of gives you an idea of
what goes on in
Sammy's head as she does simple everyday
things like getting ready for work so
it's a very short passage that explores
some of what I just said
I checked the clock 17 minutes and
Counting as I fed Shackleton and began
scavenging for clean clothes it occurred
to me how difficult these simple tasks
would be without my right arm what would
I do if I suddenly lost it in some sort
of escalator or escaped hungry lion
accident people laughed but I lived only
a few short miles from the zoo so I took
a moment to do what I always did
whenever these neuroses attacked I
reached for a sling from my pile of
medical supplies fashioned around my
right arm and continued my routine with
this new handicapped confident that I
would be the one with the last laugh
when I was so ludicrously prepared for
life without my right arm amazing they'd
all say can you stand how quickly she's
adapted why she's just as capable as she
was before maybe even more so and thanks
to my brilliant foresight it would be
true I just nod and smile and continue
my life is a well-prepared one-armed
genius I snapped myself out of this
daydream to concentrate on the
extraordinarily difficult task of
opening a container of yogurt with just
my left hand and then as I gathered up
my work folders cleverly using my foot
to lift my briefcase up to the table I
caught sight of Shackleton's mossy gills
oh no the mossy gill death sentence I
had managed to inadvertently murder
eight Japanese fighting fish over the
course of the previous 11 months I had
never meant to kill them in fact I did
absolutely everything by the book but
they still died mr. Lee the pet store
owner assured me I hadn't done anything
wrong I secretly suspected he was
keeping something from me some critical
piece of caretaking instruction or water
purifying product that would keep my
fish alive because whatever it was by
withholding it he ensured my lucrative
repeat business
he played the helpful counselor however
and according to him the Japanese
fighting fish sometimes just lost their
will to live after a simple change in
surroundings and performed a sort of
fish style Harry Caray three of them
wasted away two of them became grossly
bloated and Jacque Moby and Ballard had
all developed mossy Gill disease I
looked sadly at my ninth and longest
living fish the six-month trooper whom I
thought had changed my luck Shackleton
so named for miraculously surviving an
unfortunate winter time power outage
that had turned his bowl into an
icebound wasteland stared bravely back
amazingly he had lived through being
thawed out I had assumed this proved he
was some sort of fish Messiah a powerful
spiritual leader of the marine realm but
I should have known that even the
mightiest of fish couldn't survive for
long and my murderous clutches I was
beginning to obsess about the
implications for my fitness as a future
mother if I couldn't even keep a tiny
little fish alive for more than a few
months when I caught sight of the clock
12 minutes I quickly grabbed some
magazines for the commute and rushed out
the door barely remembering to shed my
sling along the way no Sammy works for
as I mentioned her hometown senator and
his name is Senator Robert Geary she
calls him our G for short and this next
passage is a little bit longer and I
need to set up a couple things because
it's around page 58 in the book so so
you know what's going on
RG has a very professional demanding
relationship with Sammy she's always
sort of she's very new to DC and she's
very worried that she's gonna lose her
job she is constantly trying to prove
herself and do a good job and and so she
always feels a little bit like she's
skating on thin ice with our G and also
his are G's wife and two baby boys or
make a little cameo in this passage and
that was just well you'll just see them
and that's now you know they it kind of
shows for her some of what goes on
behind the scenes on the hill with
people's families sort of going in and
out of the offices occasionally the
other thing you need to know is by this
point she has met and been intrigued by
a guy named
Aaron who is a speechwriter for a rival
senator and her boss RG and senator
Bremen are working together and RG has
warned her specifically to watch out for
Bremen and to be very wary of his his
staff as well but she can't help but
still be intrigued by by this guy Aaron
and oh you need to know it's it just
gets a reference to that they the way
they met was briefly it was in a bar and
Sammy had managed to upend a pitcher of
beer on some people and Aaron rescued
her came to her aid basically and that's
just referenced in an email exchange so
that that makes sense and the tension
between them I already mentioned the
other two things Liza is Sammy's best
friend I don't need to go too much into
her character because she just starts
out this passage with a phone call but
that's who Liza is and one other
reference is to meditation and that's
because earlier right before this starts
Sammy has she's woken up for work and
she has heard that meditation is really
healthy to kind of in the in a quest for
spiritual wholeness and relaxation she
decided to give it a shot and she fell
asleep and that made her late for work
so that just gets referenced so you know
so it starts out with Liza and a phone
conversation while she while Sammy's at
work Liza interrupted the campaign
update by calling to vent about a
co-worker who noisily cracked his joints
no you're not being unreasonable it is
gross I commiserated have you said
anything to him she hadn't the worst is
the thing he does with his neck he warms
up to it by doing all his knuckles in
order followed by his ankles then he
rolls his head around and unleashes this
disgusting finale of crackling Pops okay
stop
you're making me nauseous I know it's
sickening
I can hear these little gurgles like his
veins are being squelched or something
and Liza I'm serious oh right sorry it
was too late my limbs had gone weak for
a healthcare analyst obsessed with
obscure diseases I had a remarkably low
tolerance for any discussion of necks
wrists or Achilles heels it was a nod
phobic trifecta I tried to avoid
divulging to anyone but close friends my
psych major college roommate had
it was fairly normal for people to feel
skittish about these body parts because
there were human beings most vulnerable
points but I'd never met anyone who
seemed was bothered by them as I was
once I've been forced to think about any
of the three in a concentrated way I
pretty much had to take a five-minute
timeout to recover and if confronted by
any visual depiction of harm to these
areas the damage could be much more
severe there were a remarkable number of
movies that featured suicides via
violence to the wrist area and more than
once I'd had to be helped out of
theaters and given paper bags to breathe
in to in short Eliza should have known
better can you move your arms yet she
asked guiltily I'll be okay I whispered
bravely I was still feeling a bit limp
10 minutes later when I had to brief RG
on a conference call that afternoon with
a group of hospital administrators he
looked WAN and stressed again that we
seemed to be absorbing all the
background I was downloading he fiddled
with his watch as I wrapped up okay
sounds good are you setting up the call
yes yes sir and I'll just stay on and
follow up afterwards he nodded and
fought back a yawn I wondered how much
sleep he'd gotten the night before
perhaps he'd benefit from a little
meditation RG checked his watch a final
time and brightened suddenly Jenny and
the boys are stopping by in a few hours
on their way back from the museum he
told me for no apparent reason other
than the fact that he seemed excited
about it that was another thing I liked
about RG he had a very pure boyish
quality about him when he was happy and
his wife and children seemed to make him
happier than anything else could I had
always found this refreshing
particularly in an environment where too
many people seemed to treat their family
members as necessary props to be
occasionally trotted out he had avoided
the majority of the time that's great
I'd love to see them the boys must be
getting big it felt odd talking to RG
about anything besides work especially
in such an informal friendly way though
I was only reciprocating this tone I
worried it was still somehow
insubordinate but I was curious to see
the boys Jack and Jeffrey Garry had been
born the same week I'd begun work in our
Gees DC office accordingly there was a
part of me that felt that my
professional arc was somehow
developmentally tied to their progress
we were certainly both associated with
the same senator I stopped musing about
how the twins and I had both been
cutting our teeth in different ways over
the past few months and tuned back in
with the uncomfortable feeling our G had
just said something I hadn't registered
pardon me sir I asked he enunciated
tersely
what you're still doing here aren't we
okay friendly time over I scurried back
to my desk to begin setting up the
conference call but was delayed by the
arrival of an email from Aaron -
Samantha Joyce from Aaron driver subject
best date ever text Sammy we still on
for tonight don't torture me say yes how
about meeting at the Oval room bar not
actual unless you can arrange entrance
in which case let's go crazy around 8:00
I figured we could throw some beer on
some people before grabbing a bite to
eat somewhere let me know once again I
hesitated for a moment it would be so
easy to get out of this but I knew I
didn't want to - errand driver from
Samantha Joyce subject read best date
ever text I'll see you there at 8:00
I'll be the lady needed to be rescued
from the angry mob I found it slightly
more difficult than usual to concentrate
on the work at hand but managed to set
up the conference call without a hitch a
few hours later I was passing by our DS
office on my way to the hall when I
heard the sound of babies giggling
apparently Jenny and the twins had
arrived Samantha come in here and settle
this would you ROG called out to me
settle what did I have to take sides
choose between my boss and his wife this
seemed like a lose-lose situation
absolutely sir I chimed when I walked in
the office Jack and Jeffrey were
crawling around on the couch what do you
need sir I asked professionally hiding
the fear in my voice Jenny and I have
tiebreaker shots to make but the twins
just woke up do you mind watching them
for just a second Jenny was holding our
Gees nerf basketball in her hand the
hoop hung on the private restroom door
behind them
it wasn't normally there our G only
brought it out for special occasions
Jenny looked reproachfully at our G she
was 41 and softly pretty and she carried
her gently curvy five four frame with
the directness it hinted at her sharply
active mind I still didn't know her well
but I'd heard bits and pieces about her
from other people in the office
apparently she and RG had been grad
school sweethearts and as her husband
had worked his way through Congress she
had worked part-time while desperately
trying to conceive it had taken over a
decade and lots of fertility treatments
but she'd finally become pregnant since
the twins birth a year ago she had
devoted herself to motherhood and
beneath the fatigue she glowed like
she'd won the lottery however at this
exact moment she looked disapproving
Robert you can't ask her to do that she
said our G turned back towards me look I
know it's illegal to ask you to do this
in the capacity of being my employee so
you just do it as a friend leave ten
minutes early or something to even
everything out of course shoot away I
answer
Jack and Jeffrey were stereotypically
adorable all dimples and huge blue eyes
they peered out eagerly from the cave of
couch pillows that had cushion their nap
taking in the many of the sights and
sounds as they could gather I stared
back at them marveling and knew at how
completely identical they were in fact
the only way to tell them apart was
their different colored overalls Jack
was in blue Jeffery green or was it the
other way around the one wearing green
began to cry the Gary's immediately
looked over everything's okay I said
confidently as I began to bounce him
gently on my knee it's all right Jeffrey
Jenny called soothingly before returning
to their game Jeffrey's identity
confirmed
I collect maternally at him as I bounced
Jack stopped his crawling to stare at me
his expression seemed to convey that he
hadn't realized I could make such noises
I was accustomed to be an underestimated
slowly Jeffery stopped crying
I very dry cl' ox with some winks and
moves to keep jack's interest i was all
of a sudden reminded of a loathsome
article in one of those magazines that
focused exclusively on how to keep a man
interested in one's bikini-ready body
the article had suggested trying new
things in bed like role-playing it read
even if you're not one for bestiality
pretending to be a barnyard animal can
really turn a guy on even if you're not
one for bestiality the phrasing
suggested that being for or against
bestiality was a casual decision that
could go either way I'd picked up the
magazine in the interest of getting
rock-hard buns in ten minutes or less
and here I'd been confronted with an
implicit acceptance of sex with animals
I'd been alarmed at the time and was
distressed to recall it now especially
with two one year olds watching me
intensely I hoped the memory of that
horrid article wasn't projecting out of
me and smudging up their auras it didn't
seem to be they were both grinning at me
happily they really were amazing as I
gained which as I gazed maternally back
at them I felt an unfamiliar warm
feeling it took a moment to realize the
source Jeffrey was joyfully pissing
through his diaper onto my suede skirt
staying calm was my second instinct by
the time I had determined that was the
best course of action I couldn't retract
my first one which was to shriek and
damage his way at alarm the Gary's
sprinted over and snatched the boys up
asking me worriedly what was wrong what
had happened
I quickly assured them everything was
fine pointed out the urine development
and apologized for overreacting
Oh God suede missus Gary said
sympathetically is that bad
RG asked I guess fabric trivia wasn't
included in the long list of things RG
knew everything about to be honest it
barely deserved to be on the list of
things I knew vaguely about when my mom
had given me the suede skirt for my
birthday a surprisingly hid present from
her she'd mentioned that spilling liquid
on it was a bad idea and it made me
promise not to wear it in the rain her
pointed tone suggested that she believed
if she didn't say anything I would rush
to change into the skirt at the first
sign of a thunderstorm I had worn it for
my date with Erin because I thought it
made me look more stylish than I
actually was
I'm so sorry Samantha will pay for it to
get dry cleaned of course Jenny Gary was
saying to me was there a one-hour dry
cleaner nearby that wouldn't mind me
waiting on premises in my underwear if
there was it probably wasn't an
establishment that would be a good idea
to frequent oh no don't worry about it
at all no problem at all I insisted as I
made my way towards the door I found it
off a few more apologies and escaped to
the restroom where I transformed the
medium-sized urine stain into a giant
sized water one before returning to my
desk in defeat I was supposed to meet
Erin in 45 minutes and I still had a
long haul list to return plus a briefing
on the National Institutes of Health new
study findings too right on top of it
all I was sick of panicking at least for
the moment there wasn't time to race
home to change and my only other option
was the gym clothes I kept
optimistically and fruitlessly packed in
a bag under my desk so he was either
going to go from a stain skirt and all
or it was his loss as I made my way to
the Oval room 40 minutes later I
pondered whether my newfound calm was
the symptom of recently contracted
mind-altering disease could I have
somehow become infected with meningitis
of the brain now that I thought about it
my neck was stiff and my head was
throbbing a bit if my fears were founded
there really wasn't much I could do
beyond deciding to make one of my last
nights alive a memorable one
this decision led me to my shot of
tequila while I waited for Erin just a
little waker-upper to get me going
followed immediately by a breath mint to
protect my reputation
Erin arrived 15 minutes late but with a
flower PEZ dispenser flower and candy
and one strong move I pointed out my
skirt stain immediately to assure him
that I was well aware of its presence he
laughed at the story which made the
whole peen episode seemed infinitely
worthwhile
Aaron steered me towards a little table
against the wall and ordered someone as
I sat across from him I felt hot and
tongue-tied as familiar waves of panic
flooded my nervous system clearly the
newfound calm had fled at least that
meant the meningitis scare was over okay
I will stop there I tried to pick
passages that didn't really go too much
into plot twists because I don't want to
give anything away but that I hope gives
an introduction of some of the other
characters that appear in the novel and
Sammy goes on to have personal and
professional adventures throughout so at
this point I'd be happy to answer any
questions if anyone has any and thank
you all for coming and it's fine if you
don't have it great I'm glad everything
was so clear I think yes it's sort of
hard to figure out exactly once I
because the threads of it went back
aways I now I mean I'll give you the
medium sized answer when I I was writing
for TV and as I said I never thought I
read about politics or government or any
of this world that changed a little bit
in December of 2002 and at that point I
was writing for a sitcom we're starting
Nathan Lane he worked for congressman
and and also I got to guess write for
Saturday Night Live and both experiences
were very fun and I realized that
writing about that world actually came
really naturally and that when everyone
tells you to write what you know they're
not steering you down the wrong path
that actually is good advice to follow
so at that point I started writing
something that when I look back on it
reminds me a lot of Sammy it's her voice
and it's kind of it was a play so it was
you know much shorter but I started that
in January and a 2003 and and also what
happened was I was though I loved
writing for TV I was starting to
a little frustrated with the nature of
TV writing where it was always writing
for someone else's character and someone
else's story and I really was excited to
get developed to develop my own
character and my own story and in a more
in depth away sort of explore world
beyond
one-liners if I could and so I really
started started it then in kind of a
bare-bones way and and it wasn't until
probably June that I made the decision
to turn down a TV series and focus
totally on writing the book which was
terrifying but allowed me to spend every
day writing just the book and when I did
that I had a draft in three months and
so then I did another draft and more
editing so it's sort of hard you know
you don't know when an idea first starts
and when but basically once I was
writing full-time - when I was
completely done it was about six or
seven months with the first draft being
done in three long answer yes I guess
when you were writing for Saturday Night
Live these were skits in script form or
they treatment first I didn't like I got
to guest right for a week and it was
sketches so you know it was yeah well
the way sir and live works is is short
sketches and you definitely type up
scripts you know but it happens very
suddenly you know you kind of come up
with the idea on Monday and the show is
live on Saturday so you do what you can
but that's what it is and then for
sitcoms it's it was you know not short
sketches it was you know a much longer
TV script so yes play with your parent
parental background and I'm writing a
story about politics there's there's
going to be comparisons that are drawn
and there was that comment in the book
about you
children that are brought out mm-hmm for
display type thing did were you
consciously did you consciously when you
wrote this book try to avoid ticking off
your parents or people they knew or how
did you handle that
that diplomacy's thing that you yeah
well I never liked taking off my parents
and read it stay on good terms with them
and luckily they were very supportive
the whole the whole way I think for me I
just approached it at from my writing
background and from a totally fictional
point of view and so I didn't and I
didn't base any character or any plot
twists on any actual person or actual
event at all I made it all up so I
didn't worry too much about that because
I really wanted to try to make try to
tell a compelling entertaining story it
was sort of my first goal but also
through the eyes of Sammy and about this
world that I think a lot of people don't
know very well and have sort of
misconceptions about most people I know
who have never been to DC think of it as
sort of you know boring stuffy place
where nothing gets done you know and I
know that so many people and a lot of
young people come here to try to to
throw themselves into work that they are
devoted to and that they think will help
improve things and I really wanted to
celebrate that impulse you know and do
that through Sammy so so that those were
sort of what I was exploring and it was
definitely all fiction so I didn't
really worry too much about it but it
was important for me that Sammy though
she has this behind-the-scenes
perspective and in purch she's not from
DC you know I kind of wanted her to be
able to experience it and comment upon
it as if anyone was popped down there
but got to see things that a lot of
other people don't get to see so I don't
know if I fully answered your question
if you because I kind of got off on some
other thoughts there
DC person I write wasn't this hard to do
today it's for her eyes thinking her as
a new person in the city I mean you've
been here since yeah I was i yes I would
my dad was elected to his first term in
Congress a couple months before I was
born so I definitely was always here and
and it but it wasn't I think because I
never I always wanted to be a writer
from when I was little and I never I was
always sort of interested in anything
that was going on in my world in a kind
of observational way you know that I
just that was sort of just my nature and
so so it actually it wasn't really a
negative for me it was much more of a
positive to have this whole this huge
well to draw on of because kind of this
place in these people were naturally
threaded through my life you know and so
it was easy to fictionalize it and easy
to try to make it real and and try to
make it funny but without having to do a
you know ton of research and come and
live in DC for a long time you know it
just came naturally because of my
background so yeah thanks anyone else
have a question yes I hated that it
ended because I'm gonna be continued
keeping Sammy's character ongoing and
doing another book with her as a
character my my publishers have talked
to me about that and I would definitely
love to do that because I didn't like
ending the book myself I kind of it made
sense to end it where I did but I kept
writing her in my head and kind of went
on with her adventures so I'm sort of
waiting to see I'm writing the
screenplay for this right now which is
really unexpected and fun and a
different experience and I'm waiting to
see after that's done and how this goes
if I still want to write more of Sammy
or want to do something completely
different and if people want to read her
or not hunter you know I'm just kind of
gonna see how it feels after I finished
the screenplay but I'm so glad that you
enjoyed it and thank you yes well I
actually asked them if they could design
it this way I'm a didn't draw it but
this was an idea that that I had because
Shackleton who you heard about is an
important character for Sammy in her
book she has a an ongoing relationship
with her fish she doesn't have a
roommate but she does have a fish that
she looks like and and so I kind of just
thought that because he actually is a
pretty plays an important role in the
book and in Sammy's life and then there
is just the metaphor you always hear
about the fish bowl of DC and someone
who's kind of plopped down into it as
Sammy is then I thought about okay if
there's in those fish bowls they often
have sandcastles or little decorations
with treasure chests and what if it was
the Capitol building and instead you
know and it kind of evolved from there
from those two ideas coming together and
I like I love the way they drew it
actually I really like the cover but
that's how it were the idea originated
and yes a general question I know the
writing process was very intense to
develop the character and create the
flow of the novel what advice would you
give to someone who's embarked on her
first novel
advice for someone embarking on their
first novel gosh I don't still feel very
qualified to answer that very important
in in my experience it was really
important to me was to take the endeavor
very very seriously you know for me it
was I made it my job you know and that
can be hard to do I think sometimes but
I was able to just take that risk and
try to do it and and even if you can't
completely spend all your days doing
that for me the discipline was really
important
and luckily went hand in hand with being
very excited to write about it so it
wasn't it wasn't I woke up every day
very excited to write you know and that
I felt lucky for but everyday it didn't
necessarily didn't necessarily lend
itself to long writing hours and that's
where I had to really set a time and
stick to it and even on the days where I
didn't feel like it if I did do it I was
ultimately so much happier that I kind
of pushed through that because I was
farther along and then the next day I'd
find myself getting excited again about
it you know so for me it was really the
discipline was really important and then
and just being really engaged with the
material too you know because if you're
so excited about what you're writing and
then it never gets old you know and then
it's still terrifying because you don't
know if anyone else is going to like it
but um but it was I think I felt so
lucky to be able to try to spend my time
doing something creative and that just
kept me going and felt really happy
about it so good luck
I didn't really I mean when I finished a
draft you know then I had my then I gave
it to my editors and you know then that
that was very helpful for shaping it but
the initial draft I pretty much did on
my own sort of in a vacuum yeah thanks
yes shaped it further well it was they
were really helpful because they were
the first people to kind of look at it
besides me so they were obviously a lot
more objective but just in terms of
shortening different things and shaping
it in a way that they moving around some
things so that the relationships made
sense where I it always made sense
because it was in my head to me you know
it always made sense but it was great to
understand from their point of view that
certain things needed to be worked on
and and it was actually a really great
experience much more fun for me I think
coming from TV where it's so
collaborative then I felt open to
listening to people who had did this for
their living you know they work with
books and I've edited a lot of books and
I felt like okay this is my first one I
have a lot to learn you know please help
be honest about what I need to do so so
they were just really helpful that way
and it ended up being a great experience
editing Wiseman anyone else we like to
get to the signing yeah okay and thank
you very very much thank you thank you
guys so much for being there
kristan Gore has written for several